but I thought that was the big dream you
come to America you make it big you make
a couple bucks you get rich boy the rich
thing's weird now feels like we hate
rich people ain't that weird see that on
line a lot like Fu the rich kill the
rich Eat the Rich like why are we all
[__] on the thing we want to be it's
like making F of old people look at old
bastard probably sh his pants you're
like yeah that's the
goal we're all kind of Hypocrites aren't
we we all go to 7-Eleven give me that
scratch off guy goes buying a
Ferrari Rich prick come on big money
which one is it all my friends very left
leaning liberal down with hate we got to
stop hate before rich people well that
feels pretty hateful well I do hate the
1% like whoa see you hate
minorities we we're all so compassionate
these days till someone's doing better
than you then [__] them you some rich
guys like yeah my beach house burned
down in Malibu everybody's like boo
[__] who he's like well you know my
kids were in
there I don't get it I invented
something now I don't have feelings